[Music]
so what happened here with
with will smith you sent me he'll be
dealing number one cool
sorry so you sent me this yeah i didn't
even get to this last i've been i've
been meaning to get to this all week
on both shows and i still haven't gotten
to this so what it what
we want to explain what this is okay so
that's will smith obviously that is
will smith fresh prince if you guys
remember there was a show called the
fresh prince of bel-air
never saw it i was watching california
dreaming is it a movie called the
independence day
never seen it bad boys the one with
sean penn suicide squad
no pursuit of happiness is that the aids
one i am legend
well that's the eighth one i don't
remember i don't know
i've heard of it oh oh this is the guy
that did that movie with martin lawrence
yeah i know who he is aladdin
robert this is robin williams he looks
terrible
he looks terrible actually looks great
that's true um
will smith is a star of a tv show that
every one of us has watched 700 every
episode of 700 times on repeat
back when tv was still a thing this is
zack morris no no no it's the black
remember the black show that you'd watch
on repeat all the time
different world it's dwayne wayne
this is kadeem hardest really does he
have the glasses still
those are cool so so what happened to
sinbad
this is sinbad right he's clearly not
wearing windbreaker material oh you're
right good point
right um we're kidding this is tiger
woods i'm so good
i'm just my house um
and this rob thomas you my [ __ ]
um is this mr cooper from hanging with
mr cooper so government oh my god
remember hanging remember how
much they pushed that show down your
throat i remember that nobody wanted it
no
it was terrible that was um
oh my god it felt like a baby getting
baby food forced in your mouth
somebody called him black morris black
morris
that's a good i love that all right
black boris so
will smith's uh married to a woman named
jada pinkett smith together they've had
two
sexually androgynous weird kids very
weird kids very odd people
uh but they they don't like each other
you just well they almost divorced a
couple years ago if i remember correctly
i think she was trying to pull him to
scientology and he was like no i'm not
doing that [ __ ] it was something like
that
i also the rumor is and this is pretty
much true for everybody in hollywood but
they kind of had one of those open
relationships
i heard like they're pretty public about
that stuff and they were going to
divorce but then they decided not to
divorce
so so she's doing what a facebook live
show is that what it is he's doing a
show now
which is like the black view
uh but it's on facebook live on facebook
actually it's on
called facebook watch facebook's trying
to do this
this says that they're trying to get
into it too like we're gonna be a
network too no you're not you're
facebook yeah
uh so i guess jada pinkett and the
daughter
and some people do the show called the
red table talk or whatever
okay and she's trying to use will to
promote it because she's not
she's she's on facebook of course yes
she's not yeah
people aren't lining up for jada pinkett
they're lining up for the smith part
right um not not not from
the woman from matrix two and you know
like they probably fight all the time
and then like any time like
any time like they probably fight she
probably says nasty [ __ ] to him and she
probably says like really nasty passive
aggressive [ __ ] like
how like if tupac wasn't dead she'd
still be [ __ ] him or something like
that you know or like or like oh yeah
you're big and smart why'd you turn on
the matrix you idiot
exactly so yeah
he turned on the matrix through the wild
wild west i think by the way
so i guess they're home right and he did
just whatever and she just starts
videotaping him so she can promote her
facebook live show i'm already matt i'm
already mad
for him because that already seems
really and like
somebody walking up to you is it a live
stream or is he just recording
uh i think it was live because if it's a
live stream that makes it even worse
like if you're recording
then you go hey don't put don't post
that kiss but if it's a live stream if
someone walks up to you in your home
with
even my wife i'd be like [ __ ] what
are you doing
so i'm sure but he reacted good right he
reacted well
he's had it with her you can just i dude
i've seen
couples where you're like oh boy they've
had it with each other this is
let's play the whole let's just play the
whole 50 minute second clip 50 second
clip without talking because people yell
at us for stopping too much
so will you know stare perel is coming
to the table she's gonna be at the red
table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and i redefining our relationship
i would say don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness
if you could fail come help us again
please
i'm still dealing with foolishness don't
no no
yeah because she could don't just would
you say
that she helped us heal the hurts that
we cause between one another my social
media presence is my bread and butter
okay so you can't just use me for social
media
and not you know don't just start wrong
i'm standing in my house
don't just start rolling please watch
a stare at the red table because she's
helped us a lot can't you tell
he has can i just i am can i say
something i am so uncomfortable i say
something right now i am so
uncomfortable
and i really wanted to play this last
night and i never got to it i just keep
getting
sidetracked with her stuff but he
has had it with her he has
had it with her you know what i mean
like there's there is uh
that was disdain dennis right
but no no no but the other thing first
off they're both douchebags can we at
least
admit that like i mean obviously he's in
the right here
but if you know you're on live saying
something like my social media is my
bread and butter
it's like i get it
but how many times has she probably been
doing this to hyper dumb
no you're right but this completely goes
against i'm sure you've seen a lot of
social
youth a lot of positive will smith
videos lately
like he's been making around on social
media like positive he did the youtube
rewind stuff like positive will smith
this kind of goes against that whole
like hey man what's up i'm will i just
like you guys
i get it what about this says he's not
just like you guys
that's a good point he's just like me
it's happening i'd be really pissed he's
had it with his wife
he wants to smash her in her dumb face
you know you think she's she's
she's not she's she's
nothing on near his level she's
literally will smith's wife
and she thinks she's a star i mean i
think everybody has
like you can relate to this you just go
baby i'm not
i'm not in the [ __ ] mood right now
you think he blames her for the way the
kids turned out
yeah absolutely you think because you
think i think there's a little guilt
deep down where he's like i should have
been around more actually chasing 20
million dollar paychecks to
you know fight with martin lawrence and
michael bay and
things um but yeah i think deep down
he's just thinking like
like i you we've this is
your rock bands and [ __ ] tupac uh
i mean i'm just i'm i
i kind of feel like you would think that
will smith
most look again like i bring up like the
way hispanics are
most black dudes aren't don't want their
kids to look like androgynous [ __ ]
carnival acts
and that's what kind of what they look
like and you know what i mean like have
you seen his son
with the [ __ ] m m dyed hair and the
grill
and and the contacts and wearing a dress
and
i i can't imagine that when your baby is
born even if you're will smith you want
your kid to turn out like that right
yeah everybody's talking about how he
made his uh kid
kissed his son on the lips on live tv in
a very pervy way i don't remember that
who will smith yeah i don't know i think
sometimes people get a little too
weirded out by that i mean my parents
never did that but i do know some
parents that did that and i don't think
that's that no i know and i know people
have kissed their kids on the lips and i
i
i didn't see the ellen clip so i don't
know but i i know i've seen people kiss
the kids on the lips and it hasn't
bothered me
yeah i mean there have been other times
how old was his kid too there have been
other times i've seen people kiss their
kids on the lips and i've been weirded
out
so i think it's really all about context
yeah i took a point you know what i mean
uh i mean i could probably find it i'm
just saying that
he yeah pull it out let's see if we can
kiss this jaden
jamie pull it up yeah it's wild
but yeah they um they they i
like i know that they're all weirdos i
get it but
here i got it i get very frustrated
sometimes